okay question because you've been you've
been to Disneyland yeah do you like the
Disneyland food do you think Disney okay
because like people always try and lie
to me and tell me that it's good and
every time I've been I've hated the food
I've only liked the popcorn that's
literally it like I don't think I've had
a single meal or snack at Disneyland
where I'm just like yes this is worth
coming back yeah yeah you know how
everyone wants to uh you actually have
turkey legs yeah it's like a thing yeah
bro it was vile I I hated this thing it
was disgusting
I do I I never understood like I never
wanted to become a vegetarian I never
had any part of my brain that made me
think that I should become a vegetarian
but seeing that kind of disgusting like
veiny gross like like red like bright
red turkey leg that I'm just chewing
into made me forget it I was like you
know what yeah no I get it this is this
is eating animals like this is
disgusting like this it doesn't even
taste good like if it tasted Divine I'd
be like all right well sorry turkeys
yeah I see but then Disneyland
Disneyland fans will come back on that
argument and being like well yeah but
like the point of Disneyland isn't the
food it's it's a lot of them swear by it
though it's the World building it's the
World building and then take me out of
it knowing that like [ __ ] Donald Duck
or Mickey Mouse is a [ __ ] chef and he
should never cooked
like honestly the best food I had in
Disneyland was the standard ass hot dog
but that's because you're a hobby yeah
hot dog and you're like
I was asleep 30 minutes
as long as it snaps yeah have you been
to Disneyland in Japan yet no do you
plan to and I have no intentions
if I didn't if I didn't go during the
pandemic there's no [ __ ] way I've
been to Disneyland and see now and both
of them were fine just fine
just not a Disney guy you know and nor
is Sydney she's not Disney yeah very
lucky huh you're very lucky that your
partner isn't like Disney obsessed I
feel like it becomes a nightmare once
they are
because you're owned by the Disney
Corporation yeah because she is and it's
so and it's so it's so I don't wanna say
it's horrible but it's so like asinine
because she got into it not because of
Disney but because the Kingdom Hearts so
it's like extra
there's always an Avenue
side and the Kingdom Heart size so it's
just like a double whammy but at least
she doesn't like drag me to go to
Disneyland because she knows I don't
like it so it's like that's fine you can
go to Disneyland it's cold I know you
paid the taxes
you've been to a theme park with a theme
park obsessed person yeah oh my God it's
the worst my uh my cousin actually my
younger cousin used to have the Disney
yearly pass uh which is like you I don't
know how much it is yeah it costs like
four tickets yeah but like I think like
I actually did the calculations it's
like it's only worth the money if you
end up going to Disneyland I think it's
like at least two or three times a month
yeah I don't I said really I thought it
was way less I thought it was like five
times a year I think it's something like
it's at least in the Japanese one it's
like two to three times a mark but my
cousin used to go every week I've never
like been a guy who like I I like theme
parks I like anything I like throw pops
I would never think about going to like
a Thrill Park or theme park more than
twice a year like ever yeah I don't know
that's just maybe my mind just like
programmed that way but once I've seen
everything once I'm like okay that was
cool I don't need to go again for a
while you know yeah they actually uh
she took it off the website actually
it's the yearly pass the animal
passports oh yeah probably probably
because of the pandemic though right
yeah I mean you know when you go with
someone who's obsessed they're like they
have an itinerary in their head and if
if you don't stick to it they get so
annoyed they're like they're like I'm
like what if I don't want to do that
ride they're like no you have to I I
optimal way because I have I have
friends who are Disneyland obsessed but
they don't like going on rides they
literally go to Disneyland just to take
photos what the [ __ ] and I'm just like
Emmett you do you don't involve me now
it's a Disneyland uh Disneyland uh Team
Labs exhibition that's that's basically
what it is
basically basically it's not exhibition
yeah it's like I don't want the
interactivity I just want to take the
photos I don't know if maybe you know
doing a ton of Anime conventions you
just turned me off this but I just don't
enjoy being in places with when I'm
shoulder to shoulder with people no and
so I've never it's like I feel like I I
just don't want to be I've never been
that way but I think being two enough
Anime conventions has just put me off
that even more yeah because I'm like God
damn nothing is more suffocating than
being in a room full of weebs and
someone there [ __ ] stinks and uh you
can't pinpoint who's Disneyland well you
know you know somewhere you know someone
here stinks well luckily Disneyland is
not as bad but
unless unless there's a wee bit not even
Disneyland but [ __ ] just like the
thought of going to Kyoto now just like
turns me off so much yeah for sure I
just don't think anything in my mind is
worth being like shoulder to shoulder
stuck to people I'm just kind of like
actually I'd rather just not I'm good
like maybe I miss out on some cool
things but ultimately I just don't want
to have to line up for like three hours
for anything or just be shoulder to
shoulder yeah I've I've realized like
I've grown too big like pet peeves like
growing up now that I just like have
like zero tolerance for and one of them
is like uh one of them is being in a big
crowded in a big Space full of crowded
people yeah and the second one is just
queuing up for an experience I guess
and Disneyland is both of them like okay
okay like if they're if if I really want
to go to a restaurant right yeah and you
have a restaurant that's like highly
acclaimed
um really got got really good reviews
but you have to wait half an hour for or
a restaurant that has no weight that
serves the same Cuisine but has lower
rated reviews I'm going to I'm going for
that one every single day I mean Japan
loves adding up for stuff yeah I mean
there's that on a Geary place we have to
wait two hours to get it on a Geary yeah
and onigiri that's like weighing up four
hours of beans on toast in the UK I look
at you like that and I'm just like how
much better could it be no it can't it
can't there's no way it can be worth
waiting two hours I refuse to believe it
hey maybe I'll get proven wrong and I'll
try it and I'll numb my pants right
unless they're like sprinkling that
onigiri with cocaine or something it's
like it's not worth it there's no way I
I refuse to believe there's even a I've
never waited that long for any food and
I thought that was worth it yeah ever
ever like but then again yeah but then
again like Japan and the concept of like
Foodies especially in Japan is is on
another level like there are there are
lots of like I know food obsessed like
Foodies all over the world that you know
you've seen and stuff like that but like
in Japan they just like when it comes to
food they just like living in an
entirely different Universe give me a
time when I can book and come in and
then I will I will wait three months for
the booking yeah experience this thing
if if needs be but if I need to like you
up I'm like no
where I draw the line because then there
are stalls that are just like so up
themselves and they're like yeah people
are willing to wait so uh we're not
actually gonna allow bookings you just
have to get there early enough and I'm
like every time I see stores like that
I'm like I [ __ ] hate you I'm sure
your food is delicious but [ __ ] you I
think sometimes the ones that don't a
lot of bookings are like really popular
restaurants or chains that know that
they'll have a consistent customer base
yeah and in their mind you know having
this table blocked off that can be
holding me eight people you know maybe
that's uh you know a ton of customers
you're losing out on that could be
coming through right okay yeah and maybe
this bucking doesn't even show yeah so
maybe in their business model because
they're so popular it makes way more
sense to not have reservations at all so
it is kind of nice being able to just
turn up to some nice restaurants and if
you're lucky and there's two of you it's
like oh cool we can just get a seat
right now right like that's nice because
I think there are pros and cons of
everything yeah for sure but [ __ ] no I'm
not waiting two hours
I'm going to like Denny's I'm not I'm
not waiting that long I'm straight up
like yeah I just I I feel like my time
is the most important aspect back to my
boat to me yeah and I feel insulted when
someone's like hey you gotta wait two
hours for onigiri I'm like it's like no
I'm going the family room I'm sorry
I like the 7-Eleven one yeah I'm chill
with it being yeah